julio de 1952 el rey faruk primero de
egipto es derrocado por un golpe militar
dirigido por un joven y ambicioso
oficial
jamal abdel nasser
y no es el fin de la dinastía de metal y
un oficial otomano que había tomado el
poder en egipto tras un golpe de estado
en el país por parte de otro joven y
ambicioso oficial
napoleón bonaparte julio de 1799
el general bonaparte desembarca en
alejandría egipto
es un país que ha estado dormido durante
siglos y la llegada de los franceses es
un shock un choque con la modernidad
los egipcios ven llegar a gente de otro
planeta
un otro planeta
la ambición de esta campaña egipcia
cortar la ruta inglesa hacia las indias
en menos de un mes bonaparte llega al
cairo y somete a los príncipes mamelucos
gobernantes de facto de la provincia
otomana y buena parte tiene una
particularidad se presenta como el amigo
de los musulmanes
tiene una sincera atracción por el islam
ha leído el corán o ha leído a los
orientalistas en su tiempo
junto pero en caído la población se
revela en oriente medio su ejército
contrae la peste bonaparte siente que su
suerte cambia y poco más de un año
después de su llegada regrese a francia
un oficial otomano mehmet ali se
aprovechará de esto y retoma el poder
y estableció un nuevo poder en egipto
con la idea de imitar completamente a
francia en todas las regiones del mundo
ha habido un acontecimiento que les ha
hecho darse cuenta de lo atrasados que
estaban frente a los occidentales para
el mundo árabe el acontecimiento que
sacudió la conciencia de la gente fue la
campaña egipcia mismo ya su difusión
sentí la company dijo mehmet ali es
considerado el fundador del egipto
moderno en 1830 ofreció a francia un
abel isco erigido por ramsés segundo
como señal de buena voluntad